Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Ça y est, on est reconfinés. J'espère que vous prenez soin de vous, que vous minimisez vos contacts et surtout, surtout, que vous portez bien votre masque de façon à couvrir votre bouche et votre nez.
Je crois que je pourrais faire un podcast entier pour parler des pulsions violentes que j'ai quand je vois tous ces gens dans les rues de Bruxelles qui ont leur nez à découvert.
Je sors très peu et à chaque fois ça me donne envie de sortir encore moins. Heureusement, j'ai bien mieux à vous proposer puisque voici aujourd'hui un épisode avec non pas un, mais deux invités d'exception.
J'ai eu la chance de recevoir Elisa Rojas et Alistair Houdayer. J'étais ressorti plutôt content de l'épisode qu'on avait enregistré en septembre avec Marie Peltier et Florence Hainaut.
Je trouvais que ça fonctionnait plutôt bien d'avoir deux invités qui peuvent se compléter, échanger leur vécu. Et du coup, j'ai retenté l'expérience avec Elisa et Alistair.
Vous me direz ce que vous en avez pensé. N'hésitez pas à m'écrire sur les réseaux sociaux. Perso, je suis très content du résultat.
On retrouve sans plus attendre Elisa Rojas et Alistair Houdayer. C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Elisa Rojas. Elisa, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Elisa, tu es avocate au barreau de Paris. Tu es cofondatrice du CLHEE, le Collectif Lutte et Handicap pour Égalité et Émancipation.
Et depuis peu, tu es romancière puisque tu as publié il y a quelques jours le roman Mister T et moi.
Ravi de t'avoir avec nous.
Moi aussi.
Nous sommes également rejoints aujourd'hui par Alistair. Salut Alistair.
Bonjour.
Très content de t'avoir avec nous également.
Alistair, tu es youtubeur pour la chaîne H Paradoxæ. Tu réalises des vidéos sur des sujets qui regroupent, entre autres choses, la neurodiversité, la transidentité, le handicap et évidemment l'autisme puisque, comme moi, tu es autiste.
Chouette. Tu es comédien aussi, principalement au théâtre, parce que j'ai appris que tu n'aimais pas le cinéma, on en reparlera.
Et tu es auteur puisque tu as écrit Plume, fable duveteuse pour interprète étrange, dont on parlera plus tard.
Ravi de vous avoir tous les deux. Malheureusement, aujourd'hui, on ne va pas parler de droit ou de théâtre puisque je pense que,
comme vous en avez un peu l'habitude, je vous ai réunis aujourd'hui plutôt pour parler des questions autour du handicap.
Il y a de nombreuses personnes qui sont handicapées dans le monde, mais elles apparaissent relativement rarement dans les médias.
Aujourd'hui, là, tout de suite, on est trois personnes à connaître une ou plusieurs formes de handicap, entre guillemets, autour de la table.
Est-ce que vous pouvez un peu m'expliquer, déjà pour vous présenter un peu, votre rapport au handicap et ensuite ce qui vous a amené à prendre la parole, contrairement à ces nombreuses personnes handicapées qu'on n'entend pas trop,
ce qui vous a amené à prendre la parole et à rentrer dans l'espace médiatique pour, voilà, parler du handicap.
Elisa, est-ce que tu peux m'éclairer là-dessus ?
En fait, il y a plusieurs questions dans la question, donc là je suis perdue déjà. Mon rapport au handicap, je pense que là, par contre, ça fait sujet de dissert', c'est hyper vaste.
Donc là, je sais pas trop quoi répondre de but en blanc. Mais par contre, comment j'en suis arrivée à prendre la décision de m'exprimer à ce sujet, ça, c'est à la limite peut-être un peu plus simple d'y répondre.
Bah, c'est en fait, je pense vers l'âge de 20 ans à peu près que j'ai commencé à raisonner autour de toutes ces questions, de ce que ça représentait ou pas d'être une personne handicapée et même d'être une femme handicapée.
Donc ça a pris vraiment de très nombreuses années avant que je comprenne exactement ce que ça signifiait pour moi et ce que ça signifiait aux yeux de la société.
Donc ça a été une longue prise de conscience, on va dire, parce qu'en fait, les choses, elles se font pas comme ça, de façon miraculeuse.
On se réveille pas le matin en disant : « Oh, le validisme, le patriarcat et tout ». C'est pas comme ça que ça se passe, en fait.
C'est vraiment quelque chose qui est très progressif
et qui prend beaucoup de temps. Exactement. Étape par étape. Il y a des accélérations, il peut y avoir des à-coups, il peut y avoir des choses qui vont à un moment donné se mettre en place plus vite, mais c'est quand même un processus, on va dire.
C'est un processus et qui prend beaucoup de temps. Et du coup, j'ai essayé de justement l'expliquer dans mon roman, puisqu'il y a eu un élément qui m'a aidée à déclencher une réflexion très intense sur le sujet.
Et en fait, au bout du compte, je me suis... après avoir réalisé que j'étais certainement pas la seule à vivre les mêmes difficultés,
que je trouvais de plus en plus insupportables, je me suis dit : « Si on veut briser le cercle vicieux et si on veut que certaines injustices cessent, il va falloir à un moment donné les expliquer, en fait.
Prendre la parole publiquement
et expliquer comment nous, en tant que personnes concernées, on voit les choses,
étant donné que les descriptions qui sont faites par les personnes qui sont pas concernées sont à côté de la plaque et qu'on peut pas continuer à les laisser parler seules ».
Et du coup, je me suis dit : « Moi, ayant fait du droit, j'aime écrire et j'ai pas de problème avec les prises de parole publique.
Si moi-même, dans la position que j'ai et avec ces facilités-là, je ne le fais pas, je suis encore plus responsable et encore plus complice de la poursuite du système.
Donc il faut que je le fasse, il faut que je me lance ». Et en fait, la première chose que j'ai faite, c'est d'écrire au sujet de la fameuse émission le Téléthon.
Parce que l'une des premières choses qui m'a interpellée, ce sont les représentations, parce que c'est ce qu'il y a de plus évident, on va dire,
ce qui vous frappe en premier quand vous êtes jeune, l'absence de représentation ou les mauvaises représentations.
Et du coup je me suis dit que c'était vraiment une émission qui était symbolique à cet égard-là,
puisque c'est l'une des plus... 'fin c'est la seule en fait qui est véritablement connue et où on voit des personnes handicapées mises en scène
dans un contexte très particulier.
Et je me disais...
Tu parles généralement du Téléthon en disant que c'est une géante opération de communication.
C'est ça. Exactement. Donc du coup je me suis dit c'est un exemple, c'est pas,
c'est une manifestation du problème, d'un problème beaucoup plus large évidemment, mais c'est une manifestation ultra visible et que tout le monde connaît en fait.
Personne ne peut, voilà, personne n'ignore ce que c'est que cette émission. Donc commencer par critiquer cette émission,
bah ouais, c'est la façon que j'ai trouvée pour commencer à prendre la parole publiquement et à essayer d'expliquer comment moi j'analysais les choses en fait.
Alors plein de sujets que tu soulèves et qui me donnent des, voilà, des idées de questions que je te poserai dans un instant.
Mais avant ça, je vais juste redonner la parole à Alistair. De ton côté, puisque voilà, vous avez tous les deux...
bah déjà vous avez pas le même âge, donc peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion d'en reparler, mais au niveau générationnel il y a peut-être un rapport au handicap qui a pu évoluer.
Je ne sais pas, c'est une question que je me pose. Et d'autre part, bah vous n'avez pas les mêmes handicaps, vous n'avez pas les mêmes vécus.
Donc voilà, ça m'intéressait d'avoir un petit peu les deux, voilà, comparer un peu les deux parcours, comparer les deux angles que vous avez.
Alistair, de ton côté, ton rapport au handicap et ce qui t'a amené à prendre la parole, voilà, que ce soit sur YouTube ou dans les médias.
Bah je suis globalement assez d'accord avec Elisa. Sur la question de mon rapport avec le handicap, c'est vrai que c'est une question qui est très large.
Elisa comme moi, il me semble, on est nées avec en fait. Donc je sais pas, c'est un peu comme si on me disait mon rapport avec genre mon corps ou mon visage ou je sais pas.
Il y a des choses à dire, mais là comme ça à résumer, c'est sûr que c'est une question un peu compliquée. C'est mon rapport à moi quoi, c'est moi en fait...
Bien sûr.
...mon handicap.
Mais sinon, tu parlais des différences potentiellement générationnelles. Alors je sais pas du tout quel est le vécu d'Elisa là-dessus, donc peut-être qu'en fait c'est pareil.
Mais c'est vrai que moi un des moments qui a été vraiment déclic, c'est quand j'ai fait un burn out. En fait, ma santé mentale s'est clairement dégradée pendant toute ma scolarité quoi, du début jusqu'à la fin.
Et à la fin du lycée j'ai fait un burn out où pendant six mois j'ai pas réussi à genre manger tous les jours, dormir tous les jours, me laver tous les jours, tout ça.
Et c'était vraiment... j'ai l'impression que je me suis épuisée depuis ma naissance jusqu'à mes 18 ans et qu'en fait j'ai dû me reconstruire à la fin parce qu'il restait plus rien quoi.
Et du coup ouais, pour moi le déclic en fait il y avait quelque chose de l'ordre de la survie quoi. C'est-à-dire que je voyais ma santé et mes capacités cognitives et mes capacités physiques se dégrader petit à petit.
Et à un moment j'ai réalisé que juste si je continuais dans ces là, bah j'allais mourir en fait. Et il y a un moment je me suis dit : « En fait il se passe quelque chose ».
Et du coup c'est là où je me dis que peut-être mon expérience est potentiellement pas la même qu'Elisa, mais pour moi en ligne il y avait déjà beaucoup de choses à ce moment-là.
On était en 2015, 2016.
Et du coup je connaissais déjà par exemple des personnes autistes que j'avais rencontrées sur Internet pour d'autres raisons,
notamment via des groupes sur la transidentité, parce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de personnes handicapées et trans, et trans et handicapées.
Donc en fait via ce réseau-là dans lequel j'étais déjà, j'avais rencontré un certain nombre de personnes handicapées et de personnes handicapées potentiellement un peu politisées sur ces sujets-là.
Donc c'est vrai qu'il y a pas vraiment eu, pour moi personnellement hein, c'est le cas pour beaucoup d'autres personnes, mais pour moi, il y a pas vraiment eu un moment de grand vide quoi.
Il y a pas eu un moment où je me suis dit : « En fait, il se passe quelque chose d'horrible ou de difficile ou de douloureux ou de dangereux.
Je suis handicapée et il y a personne avec qui je peux en parler
». Ça moi j'ai eu la chance que ça n'arrive pas parce qu'en fait j'avais déjà des personnes handicapées autour de moi et je suivais déjà, bah par exemple Mathieu de la chaîne Vivre Avec qui fait du contenu sur le validisme, tout ça.
Donc il y avait un moment où en fait, le moment où ça m'est vraiment tombé dessus et où j'ai vraiment réalisé, j'avais déjà des débuts de clés, des débuts d'armes et des débuts de communauté en fait et d'aide communautaire.
Et du coup, bah c'était naturel de profiter de ces outils-là et de ces personnes-là que j'avais autour de moi et qui pouvaient m'aider.
Et à un moment quand tout ça m'a permis de me reconstruire et de fonctionner, j'ai eu l'impression que c'était à mon tour de donner en fait quelque part.
Et j'avais déjà ma chaîne YouTube sur laquelle je parlais surtout de transidentité. Et au moment où je me suis sentie
sûre de moi et construite et fonctionnelle dans mon quotidien et dans ma compréhension de mon handicap et du validisme.
Alors évidemment sans dire que je savais tout ou quoi, mais je commençais à comprendre à peu près ce qui se passait et à me dire : « Voilà, j'ai l'impression d'avoir accumulé un peu du savoir et des tips du quotidien.
Et c'est le moment où moi peut-être je peux donner de la même manière que j'ai reçu quoi ». Et c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé à en parler en vidéo.
Super. Alors de nouveau plein de sujets que j'ai envie d'approfondir. Le truc qui me vient là, je repense à ce qu'évoquait Elisa il y a un instant au niveau de voilà la prise de parole.
J'ai l'impression, et vous pouvez me corriger si je me trompe, que souvent on va parler à la place des personnes handicapées,
que ce soit voilà le monde médical ou que ce soit les associations de parents.
Ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai aussi beaucoup vu en ce qui concerne l'autisme.
Est-ce que faire ce, voilà ce que je pourrais appeler une forme de self advocacy, cette forme de se représenter soi-même, parler pour soi-même,
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est un challenge quand on parle des enjeux du handicap ?
Oui je pense que c'est réel, que pour le moment et, 'fin, historiquement c'est quand même plus la parole des proches et de la famille
des personnes concernées et leur narration en fait qui a de l'écho médiatiquement.
C'est la seule qui est retenue en fait. Et on a beaucoup de mal à imposer ce dont tu parles, c'est-à-dire la parole des personnes qui sont directement concernées.
Mais je pense qu'on est en train d'émerger là, ça commence et que les réseaux sociaux nous ont beaucoup beaucoup aidés en la matière, mais qu'il faut continuer évidemment parce que pour le moment ça reste à mon sens inéquitable.
Et en fait pour revenir
à la question sur la génération, je trouve que c'est une question qui est hyper intéressante parce que je pense qu'il y a quand même quelques
choses qui ont, qui sont différentes et qui ont bougé notamment grâce aux réseaux sociaux et à Internet.
Puisque moi quand j'avais une vingtaine d'années, j'avais vraiment très peu accès à des informations sur le handicap et notamment sur tout ce qu'on pourrait appeler l'analyse politique quoi.
Enfin tout ce qui est contenu dans les disability studies. Je savais même pas que ça existait en fait.
Si je ne dis pas de bêtises, ça n'existe toujours pas vraiment en France.
Voilà, mais je savais même pas que ça existait dans d'autres pays en fait. C'est-à-dire que j'avais zéro accès aux textes,
à l'information, à ce qui avait ce type de raisonnement, de recherche, de militantisme et tout.
Vraiment, j'ai commencé à le savoir une fois que j'étais proche de mes 30 ans. Donc en fait ce qui s'est passé, c'est que j'ai dû moi-même, pour m'en sortir, et aussi pour...
'fin quand tu parles de survie Alistair, je comprends hyper bien parce que pour moi c'était pareil, c'est une question de survie.
'Fin pour que je puisse me maintenir en vie, il a fallu que je reconstruise quelque chose qui en réalité existait déjà depuis les années 70, j'aurais bien aimé le savoir.
Et que je le fasse à ma façon, c'est-à-dire seule, de façon instinctive et aussi bien sûr de façon, c'est... 'fin en passant par la réflexion.
Mais ce que je veux dire c'est que la seule chance que j'ai eue, c'est que j'ai toujours été politisée parce que je viens d'une famille qui était politisée.
Donc j'ai toujours eu une réflexion politique, mais par contre, je faisais pas la connexion entre ce que je pouvais savoir,
'fin concernant l'histoire d'autres luttes et le handicap et le fait d'être une personne handicapée.
Il me manquait un bout de raisonnement. Et en fait à force de poser les choses à plat, j'ai fini par reconstruire le discours des disability studies toute seule dans mon coin.
Mais, 'fin voilà. 'Fin c'est quand même assez horrible de se dire que si j'avais eu accès à ces choses-là plus jeune, eh ben j'aurais gagné du temps en fait, sans doute.
'Fin j'espère. Donc l'idée aujourd'hui, c'est de faire gagner du temps aux plus jeunes en essayant de produire ce qui nous manque.
Je posais tout à l'heure la question de tout simplement : pourquoi vous, pourquoi toi et Alistair, vous avez pris la parole et pas les autres ?
Et ce que je pense comprendre d'après ce que tu dis, c'est
de nombreuses personnes qui ont, voilà, des parcours similaires aux vôtres ne vont pas forcément être en mesure de politiser la question, d'avoir un regard,
voilà, politique sur leur situation et vont, voilà, 'fin on va approcher tout doucement la question du validisme, mais vont
avoir ce regard
validiste sur eux-mêmes ou sur elles-mêmes et pas forcément avoir la démarche que vous avez eue.
Et toi, d'après ce que tu dis, c'est en grande partie le fait que tu as évolué dans un milieu qui de base était déjà assez politisé pour te donner un peu l'étincelle de base si j'ai bien compris.
Oui, je pense que ça a beaucoup joué parce qu'il y avait des mots dans ma famille qui étaient pas des gros mots comme la politique, le militantisme.
C'était pas des choses
inconnues et c'était pas des choses qui étaient dévalorisées ou négatives.
C'est donc pour ça qu'une fois que j'ai compris enfin ce qu'il fallait faire et que,
et qu'on, et que je voyais des gens qui avaient du mal à employer le mot militant appliqué au handicap, moi par contre, j'avais aucun souci par rapport à ça.
Une fois que j'ai compris que finalement, c'était ça qu'il fallait qu'on fasse, ça m'a quand même aidée d'avoir cet historique familial pour du coup aller plus vite sur certaines choses.
Après j'avais plus qu'à transposer finalement tout un tas de raisonnements juste à la question du handicap.
Je suis très d'accord avec ce que dit Elisa et quelque chose que... alors, je sais pas si c'est aussi peut-être potentiellement un espèce de biais de sélection des personnes que je fréquente,
mais je vois beaucoup ce phénomène-là chez des personnes qui sont handicapées et LGBTI, où en fait, le fait que le militantisme LGBT, c'est un truc qui existe, c'est relativement acquis.
Tout le monde est pas forcément d'accord avec ça, mais tout le monde sait que ça existe, que genre les gays revendiquent des droits, 'fin voilà, c'est quelque chose qui se sait quoi genre.
C'est ça, voilà. Et du coup, il y a... dans mon expérience et dans les personnes que j'ai rencontrées, pas mal de gens qui en fait ont d'abord compris qu'ils étaient gays, lesbiennes, trans, etc.
Et qui du coup se sont politisés et sont devenus militants par là et qui du coup après, une fois dans le handicap se sont dit : « Ah oui, mais en fait, comme dit Elisa, on peut faire la même chose entre guillemets ».
Là où en fait des personnes cisgenre, hétéro et handicapées, en fait on n'a même pas l'idée que le militantisme handicapé, c'est quelque chose qui existe.
Moi de ma vie, à part cette année quand il y a eu la manifestation à la MDPH le 11 février je crois, j'ai jamais vu des militants handicapés à la télé.
J'ai jamais vu des débats sur les droits des personnes handicapées qui soient autre chose que du misérabilisme ou genre : « Oh comment prenons soin de nos plus faibles ?
» 'fin tu vois quelque chose comme ça. Mais l'idée qu'il y ait des luttes politiques et des groupes politiques et des activistes, c'est pas quelque chose qui dans l'imaginaire collectif existe vraiment.
Et du coup, en fait tant que tu sais pas que ça existe, tu te rends même pas forcément compte que c'est quelque chose auquel tu peux avoir accès, auquel tu peux participer.
Et j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de personnes handicapées militantes du coup viennent d'une autre forme de militantisme quelle qu'elle soit et se raccrochent là-dessus après quoi.
Tu expliquerais ça par le fait que dans les médias on ne voit pas vraiment, on n'a pas vraiment accès à des personnes handicapées militantes.
Ça ne se voit pas vraiment et du coup il y a pas, entre guillemets, l'effet boule de neige. C'est ça que tu nous dis ?
Bah je pense que c'est pas le seul paramètre, mais oui, je pense qu'il y a de ça. Et pour moi un exemple très frappant de ce que tu disais sur la difficulté à faire
du self-advocacy, de l'auto-militantisme entre guillemets quand on est handicapé, c'est Sophie Cluzel en fait.
La personne qui est, pas ministre, mais secrétaire d'État chargée du handicap en France, c'est une mère de personnes handicapées.
Alors que ben je sais pas quand on a le ministre, la ministre de l'Égalité hommes-femmes ou la secrétaire d'État de l'Égalité hommes-femmes, c'est une femme quoi, tu vois.
Et c'est pas pour dire que personne serait capable d'y mettre un homme. Honnêtement, moi je crois plus en rien arrivé là tu vois.
Ça pourrait arriver. Mais de fait pour l'instant ça n'arrive pas. Et je pense que si ça arrivait,
le tollé et la réaction populaire que ça générerait serait beaucoup plus élevé que celle qui est actuellement pour le fait qu'une personne valide est chargée du handicap en France.
Là vraiment la réaction est égale à zéro quoi actuellement. Tout le monde s'en fout. Personne n'a fait de manif pour ça, personne n'a rien dit.
Donc pour moi c'est pareil, 'fin c'est un exemple vraiment très représentatif de ça. Et j'ai l'impression que si je devais donner un autre paramètre, c'est aussi que quand même,
mine de rien, c'est un peu le principe du handicap, être handicapé ça prend du temps, ça prend de l'énergie.
Et forcément quand t'as tout ça à gérer au quotidien, c'est quand même d'autant plus compliqué de parler et de prendre le temps de produire du contenu et de se rassembler aussi.
Et c'est pour ça que je suis très d'accord avec Elisa sur la question des réseaux sociaux. Y a un truc où en fait
en tant que personne handicapée, s'organiser en présentiel,
c'est quand même un challenge vachement plus grand que pour des personnes LGBT valides par exemple ou qui du coup ont... alors y a des dangers tu vois liés par exemple aux violences policières ou des choses comme ça,
mais qui ont la capacité physique et cognitive de se rassembler en présentiel.
Et c'est pas forcément impossible quand on est handicapé évidemment, mais y a quand même des obstacles inhérents au sujet de nos luttes qui font obstacle à notre rassemblement et qu'on doit contourner.
Et y a plein de solutions pour ça, mais c'est sûr qu'il faut les mettre en place quoi.
Tout à l'heure, j'ai employé le terme de « personne handicapée ». C'est un sujet où les gens se disputent pas mal au niveau des termes.
Est-ce qu'on peut juste clarifier ça un instant ? Parce qu'on entend des termes, que ce soit « valide », « invalide », « handicapé », « personne handicapée », « personne en situation de handicap ».
Qu'est-ce que vous préférez dire et quelle séparation vous faites entre ces différents termes ?
Si je demande à Elisa maintenant.
Alors aussi étonnant que ça puisse paraître, je suis pas aussi focalisée que ça sur les termes. Parce que je trouve que très très rapidement, ça devient contre-productif et inintéressant.
Et y a il me semble des sujets quand même un petit peu plus...
Bien sûr
...voilà, plus primordiaux. Mais ce qui compte pour moi, c'est que les termes manifestent le respect. Puisque c'est quand même ce qu'on nous refuse, comme à bien d'autres groupes minorisés.
Du coup, en même temps il faut que ce soit un minimum fonctionnel aussi. Moi « personne handicapée » ça me va très bien parce que je considère que c'est suffisamment respectueux et que ça fait état d'une réalité.
Le terme « les handicapés » me plaît beaucoup moins parce que je le trouve hyper essentialisant.
Ouais.
Parce que c'est pas un adjectif en fait. Enfin c'est un adjectif pardon. Là je viens de dire une bêtise. C'est un adjectif « handicapé », c'est pas un nom.
Donc en fait le fait d'utiliser le terme de cette façon, ça donne l'impression qu'on est une espèce de groupe homogène et en plus limite flippant.
'fin y a une espèce de truc étrange quand les médias utilisent « les handicapés », c'est vraiment quasiment anxiogène quoi.
C'est un troupeau.
Voilà, c'est ça. Je trouve pas ça respectueux. Alors, et par contre l'espèce de formule à rallonge « en situation de handicap »,
je comprends quel était l'objectif de départ pour certaines personnes peut-être, qui était de rappeler quand même que c'était le fruit d'un contexte.
Ouais.
Mais il a l'inconvénient déjà d'être ultra-long dans des textes, c'est juste vraiment très, je trouve très lourdingue.
Et en plus de ça y a une espèce de truc gênant. Y a comme une espèce de gêne dans la formule qui... c'est comme si on voulait éloigner le mot « handicap » et « handicapé », comme si c'était en fait une grossièreté.
Mmh.
Et qu'il fallait, à quelle sorte... que voilà, qu'il y ait « situation de » en sandwich entre les deux.
Et on sait plus au bout d'un moment très bien de quoi on et de qui on est en train de parler, je trouve. Donc c'est un peu lourd pour peut-être pas grand-chose.
Et du coup voilà « personne handicapée » ça suffit, c'est pas insultant. Sauf si vous considérez qu'intrinsèquement le handicap est un problème.
Mais si vous y mettez pas des choses forcément négatives, ça suffit à mon avis amplement. Donc moi ce qui compte de toute façon pour moi au-delà des termes, c'est vraiment le contenu et les idées qui sont défendues.
Parce que les gens qui ont les bons termes, mais qui viennent raconter n'importe quoi comme Sophie Cluzel, je m'en fous.
Je m'en fous de ce qu'elle dit moi. Je m'en fous qu'elle dise « situation de handicap » ou « les personnes handicapées » ou voilà.
Moi ce qui compte c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle est en train de défendre politiquement et qu'est-ce qu'elle est en train de faire politiquement.
C'est quand même...
C'est-à-dire rien.
Voilà. Il me semble quand même que le message et le contenu et les idées défendues, c'est ça qui compte. Donc
Oui. Eh mais en fait je posais la question entre autres choses parce que de temps en temps je vois passer dans des tweets, beh je pense que c'était y a quelques jours dans un tweet d'Alistair, parler des valides.
Et je me disais : « Tiens », parce que bon alors c'est peut-être moi qui fais un anglicisme, mais le mot « valide » pour moi ça veut dire « thumbs up », c'est les personnes OK et les personnes invalides c'est les personnes pas OK.
Et donc j'étais en train de me dire : « Mais c'est quoi l'histoire de ce terme ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on parle des gens qui ont pas un handicap en disant ce sont les personnes valides ? »
Alors je suis pas 100 % sûre, mais de mémoire, il me semble qu'à la base ça veut dire apte au travail en fait, en français.
Et du coup les invalides, c'est généralement, c'était surtout utilisé pour genre les personnes... les blessés de guerre, ce genre de choses.
Où du coup genre, bah du coup ils avaient genre une blessure qui faisait qu'ils étaient plus aptes au travail. Il me semble que c'est ça l'origine.
Mais d'ailleurs que tu mentionnes l'anglais, je trouve ça assez intéressant parce que justement en anglais, « handicapped » c'est vu comme ultra négatif et péjoratif.
C'est limite tu t'insultes quoi. Alors qu'étymologiquement c'est vraiment le même mot.
Et je trouve ça... enfin pour moi c'est un bon exemple qu'en fait c'est pas vraiment les mots qui comptent, parce que du coup pour eux handicap c'est mal et pour nous c'est bien entre guillemets
en tant que personne antivalidiste.
Mais c'est plus l'histoire des mots et la place qu'ils ont pris dans la société. Et comme Elisa, pour moi, dans le sens du mot situation de handicap y a pas de problème,
mais dans les faits, je sais que beaucoup de personnes l'utilisent pour éviter de dire « handicapé ».
Et du coup c'est pas forcément un problème qu'ils le disent, mais quand je l'entends je me dis : « Mmh, je me méfie. Je vais quand même... je vais attendre de voir ce qu'ils vont dire » parce que c'est un peu un mot qui met la puce à l'oreille quoi.
Et oui tu disais que je disais « les valides ».
personnellement je suis d'accord avec Elisa sur le fait que genre dans un contexte formel on va dire, et surtout par des personnes valides du coup, si on dit « les handicapés » bon ça fait... c'est pas terrible quoi.
Après je trouve que ça m'arrive de l'utiliser, mais plus dans une espèce de réappropriation un peu communautaire où justement je dirais bon bah genre il y a des valides qui euh, et du coup les handis ont...
enfin tu vois. Et souvent je dis pas « les handicapés », du coup je dis « les handis » tu vois, comme si c'était un peu genre notre nom de... notre nom de groupe tu vois.
Mais pour moi c'est pas des mots corrects entre guillemets à utiliser comme nom dans une vraie discussion, dans un reportage ou ce genre de choses.
Et quand je l'utilise enfin ouais, c'est plus une espèce de retournement de stigmate ou d'expression un peu communautaire, mais c'est pas genre un joli mot à vraiment utiliser quoi, je pense.
Je suis d'accord avec toi.
Je sais pas si je suis très claire.
En fait moi je cherche le parallélisme on va dire. Donc si je dis « personne handicapée », la plupart du temps je dis « personne valide ».
Et si je suis un peu énervée, je vais dire « les valides » comme eux ils disent « les handicapés ».
C'est ça. Mais du coup une fois que j'ai dit « les valides », je vais dire « les handicapés » si je le dis dans la même phrase tu vois, histoire d'avoir une cohérence grammaticale quoi.
Mais oui enfin c'est un peu l'idée, voilà puisque bah il se trouve que le système créé par les valides a créé deux communautés, voilà.
C'est comme il dit exactement Alistair, c'est vraiment une façon de rappeler ça en réalité. Mais après c'est pas ça corre... enfin c'est pas un mot qui est ultra joli.
Effectivement quand on regarde l'historique, bon bah ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire hein. Y avait d'un côté les invalides et de l'autre les valides.
Donc ceux qui servent à rien, puis ceux qui peuvent et qui servent. En gros c'est ça. Donc c'est pas satisfaisant, mais pour le moment on n'a pas grand-chose d'autre.
Alors j'aurais encore des... je pourrais encore poser plein de questions là-dessus, mais comme Elisa l'a bien rappelé, c'est pas vraiment le centre de la discussion, c'est pas le sujet le plus important.
Je vais poser une question toute simple. Vous avez plusieurs fois évoqué le concept de validisme ou d'antivalidisme.
Alors pour ceux et celles qui nous écoutent et qui ne savent pas du tout ce que c'est, qui n'ont jamais entendu parler du validisme, de quoi parle-t-on ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est concrètement le validisme ?
Pour faire une définition très courte, le validisme c'est le système ou l'ensemble des violences et des discriminations qui sont faites à l'encontre des personnes handicapées.
Voilà. C'est une définition, ça dit pas grand-chose, mais ça explique ce que c'est quoi. Après on peut détailler concrètement comment ça se manifeste, mais l'idée c'est ça.
Et l'idée, comme le disait Elisa à un autre moment aussi, c'est justement de conceptualiser les difficultés liées au handicap comme une question politique et comme une situation et un contexte social,
et pas comme quelque chose d'intrinsèque et d'individuel.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait,
si je suis handicapée, c'est pas juste parce que par exemple j'ai une maladie chronique ou je suis autiste, c'est aussi parce que je vis dans un contexte qui ne me permet pas avec les capacités qui sont les miennes du fait
de mes maladies, de mes troubles tout ça,
d'évoluer de manière digne et autonome et de m'épanouir et de mener une vie correcte quoi.
Et du coup derrière le mot « validisme » dont la définition simple c'est la discrimination des personnes handicapées,
y a l'idée que le handicap c'est pas un truc naturel qui arrive parce qu'on n'a pas de bol et genre on est malade et c'est comme ça, mais aussi par-dessus tout un contexte social d'intégration ou de refus d'intégration et de discrimination.
Ok. Très bonne réponse. Elisa, est-ce que tu veux compléter ?
Moi je dirais que le validisme c'est un système d'oppression.
Ouais.
qui repose sur l'idée que les personnes handicapées sont inférieures aux personnes valides. Et ce qui justifie la façon dont elles sont traitées socialement.
Et moi je dirais que par exemple les discriminations, c'est une manifestation du validisme.
Mh. Ok je vois.
Mais le validisme c'est le nom du système d'oppression. Moi c'est comme ça que je préciserais les choses.
Et voilà. Donc ça repose aussi sur tout un système de représentation. Parce qu'en fait tous les systèmes d'oppression reposent sur les mêmes mécanismes.
Mh.
Et souvent y a un système de représentation qui est biaisé et qui vient justifier le fait qu'on nous traite moins bien.
Que les autres.
Ça ce sont des définitions je dirais, donc ce sont les définitions, ce sont de très bonnes réponses, mais c'est relativement, je dirais, abstrait, théorique.
Si je vous demande des exemples peut-être un peu plus concrets de comment est-ce que ça s'applique à une personne ? Beh peut-être vous deux.
Comment est-ce que ça s'applique concrètement le validisme au jour le jour, si je pose la question à Alistair par exemple ?
Ben je pense que comme beaucoup d'oppressions, comme l'a dit Elisa, y a... bon tout n'est pas comparable, mais y a quand même des schémas qu'on retrouve.
Donc y a des choses qui vont se passer à l'échelle interpersonnelle,
ben je sais pas, par exemple du harcèlement scolaire parce que t'es différent ou tu communiques d'une manière bizarre ou que t'as une tête inhabituelle, enfin je sais pas.
Et ça, ça va être plutôt à l'échelle interpersonnelle où va y avoir des violences, 'fin voilà, individuelles. Va y avoir tout ce qui est discrimination à l'embauche, au logement,
'fin je sais pas, la scolarité évidemment pareil.
Tout ce qui est... Et du coup dans les enjeux un peu plus spécifiques au handicap, on va retrouver donc... peut-être qu'Elisa en parlera mieux que moi, mais les questions d'institutionnalisation justement.
Donc y a ça et y a toute la question de l'accessibilité.
C'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit pas forcément de nier qu'en tant que personnes handicapées, on a des contraintes qui sont
intrinsèques à notre fonctionnement et que, ben je sais pas, j'ai des douleurs chroniques, la société peut faire ce qu'elle veut, j'aurai mal.
Voilà. Mais ça change rien au fait que par contre, si on me donne les moyens d'accessibilité dont j'ai besoin, par exemple avoir un fauteuil roulant, avoir des lieux qui sont accessibles aux fauteuils roulants, etc.,
j'aurais moins mal et de toute façon mes douleurs auront moins d'impact parce qu'elles vont moins impacter ma mobilité par exemple, et donc mon autonomie, etc.
Donc y a aussi toute la question de l'accessibilité qui est de dire : en fait la société a comme devoir de permettre à tous ses citoyens, toutes ses citoyennes, tous ses membres, de mener une vie personnelle
décente et de participer à la vie publique, d'avoir accès à l'espace public, d'avoir accès à l'espace politique, etc.
Donc voilà, je sais pas si c'est un peu plus concret ou si c'est toujours très abstrait, mais...
Bah oui oui, 'fin tu parles par exemple des impacts concrets sur ta mobilité. Elisa, on va parler dans un instant de l'importante question de l'institutionnalisation, si j'arrive à dire ce mot.
Mais avant ça, si je te pose la question Elisa, de concrètement,
le regard qu'on porte sur les personnes handicapées, les droits qu'on leur accorde, ce qu'on leur interdit d'être, comment on leur interdit de paraître, ce genre de choses.
Par exemple, en ce qui concerne les femmes handicapées, qu'est-ce qu'on leur interdit, concrètement ?
Ben déjà on leur interdit de rentrer dans la catégorie des femmes.
Déjà. Voilà, 'fin en fait, de toute façon le validisme il se manifeste par une mise à l'écart et par toutes les discriminations dont Alistair a parlé, par des violences, ça va de la microagression à la,
la vraie violence, et par tout un discours en fait dévalorisant.
Donc en ce qui concerne les femmes handicapées, ben c'est se trouver à l'intersection de deux systèmes d'oppression qui sont patriarcat et le validisme et qui du coup vous dévalorisent et vous infériorisent doublement en fait.
Donc les femmes handicapées, c'est, bah c'est long d'expliquer quelle est la façon dont elles sont traitées.
C'est pour ça que j'en ai fait un livre. Parce qu'il fallait quand même expliquer, dérouler et puis illustrer aussi. 'Fin moi j'ai essayé de faire ce que je ne faisais pas forcément en tenant un discours politique général, sur le plan militant.
Là, je voulais vraiment illustrer,
les manifestations concrètes du validisme, ce qui se passe dans votre esprit, ce que vous êtes, ce que vous êtes amenées à penser dans un système qui vous rappelle constamment que vous n'êtes pas, vous ne faites pas partie,
de l'ensemble de la communauté, qui vous ramène constamment au fait que vous êtes handicapée.
Dans les exemples qu'on peut par exemple trouver dans ton roman, y a l'idée que donc tu disais : on ne les considère pas vraiment comme des femmes,
on ne leur donne même pas vraiment le droit... on ne considère pas qu'elles puissent avoir une sexualité, une vie relationnelle, une vie affective.
Et y a aussi l'idée que, et si j'ai bien compris, corrige-moi si je me trompe, de manière générale, on a envie d'infantiliser très fort les personnes handicapées, de pas vraiment les considérer comme des personnes adultes ?
Moi, je pense, oui, qu'une des particularités, c'est vraiment de vouloir qu'on reste au stade de l'enfance en fait. Et de fermer les portes de l'entrée dans l'âge adulte.
Parce que devenir adulte, ça comporte des responsabilités, notamment en matière de vie sexuelle et affective.
Donc les, ben les personnes valides ne veulent pas en entendre parler, en fait. Donc ça suppose de penser le sexe, ça suppose de penser la maternité, etc.
Et du coup la solution la plus simple c'est d'essayer de vous convaincre de rester une petite fille, en fait.
Et du coup, c'est quand même un système, puisque ça, c'est vraiment une articulation entre,
entre le patriarcat et le validisme qui est super compliqué parce que la sensation qu'on a, c'est qu'on n'existe pas en tant que femme adulte et que du coup, on a beaucoup l'impression que le handicap efface le genre.
Et plus le temps passe et plus j'ai l'impression que c'est encore plus complexe que ça en fait, plus compliqué que ça. C'est plus sournois et hypocrite que ça.
Puisqu'en réalité notre genre il est présent, il est là, il est en sourdine, on est traitées socialement comme des femmes, surtout pour tout ce qui est négatif, c'est-à-dire qu'on est,
c'est-à-dire qu'on est en première ligne au niveau des violences, donc c'est-à-dire que les hommes savent très bien reconnaître qu'on est des femmes quand il s'agit de nous faire du mal
et d'utiliser le pouvoir qu'ils ont en tant qu'homme dans un système patriarcal.
Donc ça prouve bien qu'on est des femmes. Et surtout faut arrêter de dire que ce qui explique les violences, c'est la vulnérabilité, parce qu'en fait on veut enfermer les femmes handicapées quand on accepte
d'envisager qu'elles puissent être adultes dans la vulnérabilité pour tout expliquer.
Alors qu'en réalité la cause première de ce qui leur arrive, y compris en termes de violence, c'est : ce sont des femmes. Point.
Et que déjà accepter cette première idée-là,
permet de dérouler le reste. Évidemment que, du fait du handicap, il peut y avoir une vulnérabilité accrue, mais y a aussi un système qui nous met dans des situations où on est transformé en proie.
Et on vous transforme en proie notamment en vous expliquant que vous n'êtes pas concerné. Parce qu'en niant le fait que les femmes handicapées sont des femmes,
on les empêche de prendre conscience qu'elles sont concernées par ces questions-là, qu'elles doivent être vigilantes, qu'elles doivent pouvoir trouver des ressources, si jamais il leur arrive quelque chose. Y a
l'institutionnalisation qui, on va en parler ensuite, mais qui est à mon avis une vraie question féministe et auquel les féministes devraient s'intéresser,
puisqu'on est dans un système qui favorise les abus et les violences sexuelles, et en plus en venant prétendre qu'il s'agit d'un système de protection.
Donc on est dans un truc totalement pervers, puisqu'en tant que femme handicapée, la première chose qu'on va vous dire si vous essayez d'évoquer le problème des violences, ça va être : « Ah mais non, mais de toute façon,
ça vous concerne pas, vous n'êtes pas sexuées, vous n'êtes pas des femmes adultes et en plus on fait tout pour vous protéger. »
Alistair, est-ce que tu veux rajouter quelque chose par rapport à ça ?
Ce qu'a dit Elisa, j'suis tout à fait d'accord, c'est tout à fait vrai.
Mais y a quelque chose d'aussi très,
très intéressant à observer, notamment, moi je l'ai vu chez moi et chez d'autres camarades trans masculins, donc des personnes qui ont été assignées femmes à la naissance et qui ont transitionné vers
un genre et une situation sociale plutôt masculine, où en fait,
le handicap des fois nous dégenre et des fois nous féminise.
C'est-à-dire que moi, depuis quelques années, j'étais en gros jamais genré au féminin dans la rue, on me disait jamais « Madame » et cetera.
Et depuis six mois, j'utilise un déambulateur et tout le monde m'appelle « Madame ». Alors que je suis la même personne, j'ai pas changé de coupe de cheveux ou quoi que ce soit, j'ai pas changé de fringues.
J'ai vraiment-- c'est la seule chose qui a-- la seule chose qui a changé concrètement chez moi.
Est-ce que c'est indicateur du fait que la posture, le fait de marcher de manière imposante, c'est lié à la masculinité ?
Ben je pense-- et parce que j'ai des amis qui ont fait genre des transitions médicales, qui ont genre de la barbe, qui ont mué et tout.
Mmm-hmm.
Et ils marchent, on leur dit « Monsieur ». Non. Ils marchent, on leur dit « Monsieur », ils sont en fauteuil, on leur dit « Madame » quand même.
Et je me souviens aussi d'une fois où j'avais posté une
une carte de communication que j'avais faite qui était en gros une espèce de carte d'urgence avec marqué voilà comment je m'appelle,
je suis autiste, en cas de tel ou tel genre de symptômes, il faut faire telle chose, tel genre de choses, il faut pas s'en occuper.
'Fin voilà, c'était genre une petite carte. Et j'étais genré au masculin dessus et y avait pas mon visage, y avait rien et les gens me connaissaient pas.
Et y avait mon prénom qui est uniquement masculin et dans les commentaires, tout le monde me genrait au féminin.
Alors que y avait vraiment aucune raison de le faire et c'était pas flou quoi en fait.
C'était pas une démarche, disons toxique ou quoi, c'était-- ces gens spontanément-
C'était vraiment spontané. Et quand je disais aux gens : « En fait non, je suis un mec », ils étaient genre : « Ah, j'avais pas vu », tu vois.
'Fin-- et y a quelque chose où
je suis pas sûr, mais dans mon analyse, y a quand même dans mon vécu des choses et dans ce que je comprends, y a un côté où en fait le handicap, c'est la fragilité et la dépendance et la soumission.
Mmm.
Et la féminité, c'est la même chose en fait. Bah évidemment pas dans les faits, mais dans l'idéologie quoi. Y a un côté où la masculinité est complètement incompatible avec l'idée d'être faible et dépendant et limité et cetera.
Et en fait-- et inversement, avant ce moment-là, j'avais l'impression qu'au contraire, j'étais moins perçu comme femme parce que j'étais handicapé.
Et que du coup y avait ce côté où j'étais juste bizarre en fait, et où les gens n'essayaient même pas spécifiquement de m'assigner un genre
et où, dans des magasins où les caissiers, caissières disaient tout le temps : « Bonjour Madame, bonjour Monsieur » aux gens devant moi, je le voyais.
Très souvent, on me disait juste « Bonjour » en fait. Et je-- 'fin voilà, y avait quelque chose de très flagrant. Et pour moi, y a ces deux choses qui cohabitent où-- en tout cas, c'est pas masculinisant, le handicap en général.
Mais y a un côté où-
Mmm. Non oui, ça rejoint directement ce que disait Olivia Gazalé quand on l'a reçue pour parler de la virilité, ouais.
Mais c'est hyper intéressant parce que sur le plan, par exemple, des représentations, de fiction à la télé ou au cinéma, eh ben on ne représente que des hommes handicapés.
Par exemple, surtout sur le handicap moteur, ce sera toujours un homme en fait. Du coup, c'est pas du tout logique. C'est très-
Effectivement.
Y a un é-- y a un-- c'est hyper intéressant, je trouve. C'est-- là, vraiment, c'est hyper intéressant parce que-
On est prêt pour un deuxième épisode.
C'est ça.
Et donc, c-- ouais, c'est théoriquement incompatible avec la virilité et pourtant les personnages handicapés sont systématiquement des hommes.
J'ai l'impression que souvent dans les représentations, 'fin, je pense aux deux, trois films que je peux avoir en tête là, c'est des hommes, mais justement parce que le schéma narratif est basé sur genre
: « Il leur est arrivé sur telle chose, mais ils vont le surmonter et être genre des vrais hommes quand même », tu vois.
Oui.
Et genre, et draguer et-- 'fin, je sais pas, j'ai l'impression que peut-être, je-- c'est une théorie hein. Mais que comme le discours qu'on veut nous vendre, c'est le fait de surmonter son handicap,
eh ben du coup, y a un côté où effectivement, on va te montrer des hommes et effectivement, le handicap va être genre une atteinte à leur virilité.
Mais plot twist, l'intérêt du film, c'est qu'on va te montrer qu'en fait non, ils sont plus forts que ça.
Je sais pas, je me dis que c'est peut-être quelque chose un peu comme ça aussi qui se passe là où en fait une femme, quelque part, de toute façon, on voulait déjà la représenter soumise et inintéressante.
Alors si elle est handicapée, qu'est-ce tu veux qu'on lui fasse faire de plus ? Tu vois, ça rajoute pas d'enjeu.
Et donc cette espèce d'inspiration porn qui va du coup nécessiter que quand même, y a un objectif de vie plus grand à atteindre malgré le handicap entre guillemets.
Et du coup, ça sert bien le discours de genre l'homme atteint dans sa virilité, mais qui va la retrouver quoi.
Moi aussi j'ai une autre théorie, mais c'est pas incompatible. C'est que,
par exemple, ben justement pour tout ce qui concerne la vie affective et sexuelle, c'est beaucoup plus malaisant et gênant pour les personnes valides qui produisent ces représentations-là, d'imaginer une femme en fait.
C'est pas possible pour eux, c'est too much. Ils y arrivent pas, parce que voilà, on n'est pas supposés être des femmes intéressantes, qui, voilà, qui puissent interagir dans des relations de ce type-là.
Donc c'est plus simple pour eux de prendre un homme parce que l'homme va trouver une femme. Qui sera une sorte d'infirmière, mais ce sera quand même une relation valable en fait.
Voilà. Donc du coup, y a aussi cet aspect de vouloir refuser véritablement de représenter des femmes pour pas avoir à parler de ce qui gêne profondément,
les personnes valides et qui sont notamment la relation entre une femme, par exemple handicapée et un homme valide, parce que c'est vraiment la relation transgressive en fait, le truc incompréhensible.
Puis y a un truc où c'est toujours les femmes qui s'occupent des personnes handicapées en fait, qui sont dans le care, qui sont dans le médico-social, qui sont infirmières, qui sont assistantes sociales, etc.
Et du coup, si tu mettais-- 'fin y a un côté où du coup, mettre un homme handicapé te permet d'avoir une représentation d'un homme dont les femmes s'occupent, ce qui est acceptable.
Alors que si tu mettais une femme handicapée, tu ferais un film avec que des femmes qui prennent soin les unes des autres entre elles.
Et ça, vraiment, j'en ai jamais vu. Par rapport à ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure, j'ai quand même oublié un gros gros niveau de discrimination et de violence qui est le niveau légal.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui en France, les personnes handicapées ne sont pas légalement égales en fait aux personnes valides et n'ont pas les mêmes droits.
Alors ça va dépendre des personnes handicapées, de leur reconnaissance, mais notamment tout ce qui est la question des ESAT.
Donc les-- bah je sais plus ce que veut dire l'acronyme, mais ce qui est des-- c'est des structures de travail pour les travailleurs handicapés, mais qui sont considérées comme des structures de soins.
C'est-à-dire qu'on dit : « En fait, on vous fait travailler, mais c'est pour votre bien, c'est pour vous intégrer socialement et vous aider à être autonome.
Et du coup, vous n'êtes pas soumis au code du travail et donc on peut vous payer en dessous du SMIC et vous n'avez pas le droit de vous syndiquer. »
Mmmh.
Malin. Et typiquement, donc y a d'autres exemples comme ça, mais pour moi c'est un des plus flagrants, c'est qu'en fait, légalement, une personne handicapée peut travailler en dessous du SMIC.
Légalement, on n'a juste pas les mêmes droits. Et c'est notamment le cas des personnes handicapées qui sont les plus isolées et les plus victimes de violences, ce sont les personnes en institution.
Cette privation de droit, c'est, voilà, ça rentre dans le contexte de cette déshumanisation que vous décrivez depuis tout à l'heure.
Le droit de se syndiquer, le droit de travailler, de vivre de son travail.
On voit aussi du coup qu'il y a vraiment une question de la, du misérabilisme qui est pas juste problématique parce qu'il est humiliant, mais parce qu'il est utilisé contre nous.
Et comme le disait Elisa, y a ce côté où on vous dit : « Non, mais en fait, on vous protège, donc c'est pas la peine de vous dire qu'y a un problème parce que c'est-- on vous protège.
» Et là, pareil, c'est : « On vous paye en dessous du SMIC, mais c'est pas un problème parce qu'en fait vous travaillez, mais c'est pour votre bien, c'est pour vous intégrer socialement.
» Et du coup y a tout ce côté vraiment, ouais, misérabiliste et charitable où en fait tout ce qu'on fait pour vous, on est quand même déjà bien sympa de le faire parce que vous servez à rien.
En gros, c'est quand même ça l'idée. Et du coup, il faut quand même pas vous plaindre que la qualité du service est pas terrible par rapport à ce qu'on donne aux personnes valides en fait.
C'est ça le propos. Et ce que disait Elisa sur les violences sexuelles, y a aussi effectivement vraiment cet enjeu légal qui rentre en compte.
Parce qu'en fait, si par exemple les femmes sont plus victimes de vio-- les femmes handicapées, je veux dire,
sont plus victimes de violences sexuelles et de violences domestiques,
c'est aussi parce qu'en fait concrètement, au niveau légal, on les rend dépendantes de leur partenaire, puisque quand on est en couple, soit on n'a plus le droit aux allocations, soit elles sont conditionnées aux revenus du partenaire.
Et du coup, des fois, c'est même pas les personnes concernées qui touchent leurs propres allocations en fait.
À partir du moment où ton salaire, il est pas à toi et qu'on te l'a supprimé parce que t'es en couple, tu peux avoir envie de partir autant que tu veux, tu peux pas parce que t'as pas les thunes en fait.
Et du coup y a une organisation de la surdépendance des femmes handicapées, encore plus que celle des femmes valides, et en tant que femme et en tant que femme handicapée du coup.
Et y a aussi toute la question de l'accès aux droits reproductifs où en fait en France, y a toujours aujourd'hui des stérilisations sous contrainte, des IVG
semi-forcées sur des femmes handicapées parce que, comme dit Elisa, ben voilà, en fait on considère que vous n'avez pas à avoir une sexualité, vous n'avez pas à avoir une famille.
Et y a aussi toute une question eugéniste où en fait on veut pas plus de gens comme vous et il faut pas vous reproduire quoi.
Y a vraiment cet enjeu-là. On veut pas s'occuper de vous, on veut pas s'occuper de vos enfants et du coup n'en faites pas et restez dans votre coin.
Et c'est-- 'fin c'est vraiment un enjeu extrêmement violent pour moi.
On parle de validisme. Le validisme, ça peut aussi être intériorisé. Je me souviens que j'ai vu il y a quelques mois, quelques semaines, une vidéo du média Brut où on voyait intervenir un camarade autiste qui parlait de sa situation.
Et on voyait, voilà, ce que-- j'hésiterais pas à parler d'une forme de validisme intériorisé, de-- il parlait de lui comme étant quelqu'un, presque un fardeau.
Et il employait également des termes, et c'est de ça dont j'aimerais parler avec toi, Alistair. Il employait des termes assez datés comme il disait qu'il avait le syndrome d'Asperger.
Est-ce que l'appellation syndrome d'Asperger, et on sait évidemment que chacun a souvent besoin de, voilà, s'approprier les étiquettes,
que les termes qu'on reçoit au moment de son diagnostic, on peut, voilà, y être attaché d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Mais si on se détache de cet aspect-là et qu'on regarde juste factuellement le sens des différentes étiquettes, est-ce que le terme syndrome d'Asperger te paraît fondamentalement validiste ?
Oui, mais je pense que c'est important de dire qu'il est validiste dans les deux sens, entre guillemets. Et en fait parce que tu parles d'une personne du coup qui se désignait elle-même comme ça.
Effectivement, je pense que, 'fin en fait j'ai l'impression qu'il est plus discriminant pour les personnes qui ne sont pas désignées comme telles entre guillemets.
C'est-à-dire que l'objectif du terme syndrome d'Asperger c'est quand même de tracer la limite et c'est ce que faisait le docteur Asperger, c'était son métier, dans le Troisième Reich.
C'était de tracer la limite-
En Autriche dans les années 40. Ouais, ouais
...voilà. C'était de tracer la limite entre les autistes. Et on parle de cette question d'anticapitalisme et de rentabilité.
C'est les autistes qu'on peut éduquer et exploiter financièrement, qui sont utiles à la société et ceux qui ne le sont pas.
Et en fait pour moi désigner une partie, la partie présumée supérieure et plus utile, d'une certaine façon, en fait c'est surtout violent pour les autres.
Parce que c'est une manière de dire : « Bon eux ça va, mais les autres quand même c'est chaud. » Et c'est vraiment ça qui est derrière.
Et c'est pas-- 'fin, c'est particulièrement j'ai l'impression visible sur l'autisme où encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens sont persuadés qu'y a plusieurs formes, plusieurs types, plusieurs niveaux de sévérité.
Mais c'est quelque chose de je pense beaucoup plus large à la question du handicap où en fait, on est tout le temps en train de trier de la manière qui nous arrange.
C'est-à-dire que on est toujours prêt à te dire que t'es trop handicapé pour être autonome, pour avoir une opinion, etc.
quand il s'agit de te couper des droits et de faire des choses à ta place. Mais on est toujours prêt à te dire : « Oh non quand même, il faut pas vous laisser abattre, faut surmonter tout ça, il faut retourner au travail
» quand il s'agit de refuser des aides pour pas dépenser de l'argent.
Et ce, aux mêmes personnes. C'est pas nécessairement juste séparer une cat-- les gens qui sont trop handicapés et les gens qui sont pas assez.
On est tous simultanément, quasiment tous, simultanément trop handicapés pour être respectés et pas assez handicapés pour qu'on nous aide correctement en fait.
Et du coup, cette distinction-là elle est vraiment,
elle est vraiment intrinsèque j'ai l'impression à la manière dont fonctionne le validisme qui est de toujours trouver une porte de sortie, pour nous la mettre à l'envers si j'ai envie de dire.
Mais en fait le propre d'un système d'oppression, c'est justement ça en fait, c'est les injonctions contradictoires et également la hiérarchisation au sein même du groupe opprimé.
Pour que y ait de la division. Parce que qui dit division dit du coup plus de difficultés à s'allier collectivement pour,
véritablement remettre en cause bah le système d'oppression lui-même et puis s'en prendre à celui qui pose vraiment problème, à l'oppresseur.
Et du coup évidemment en créant des hiérarchies au sein des handicaps, et ça c'est le cas pour tout type de handicap hein.
Ouais, carrément.
Parce que dans les institutions par exemple, on va retrouver des rapports de force qui sont les mêmes que ceux de la société hein, et qui sont, bah des garçons sur les filles, des,
de ceux qui vont avoir moins de dépendance ou un handicap, voilà, qui va pas affecter par exemple l'expression, etc.
Qui vont s'en sortir entre guillemets mieux, qui vont pas être traités de la même façon que ceux qui vont avoir des difficultés à s'exprimer, vont être plus dépendants ou vont avoir un handicap mental au lieu d'avoir un handicap moteur.
Ça c'est vraiment le propre du système d'oppression, de convaincre une partie des personnes que, voilà elle est différente de personnes dont en réalité elle est pas si différente que ça.
Et c'est pour que le truc fonctionne sinon ça fonctionnerait pas.
Ouais, c'est récursif quoi. On intègre-- 'fin les personnes oppressées intègrent elles-mêmes le système d'oppression comme quelque chose d'évident, de tout à fait naturel, d'inquestionnable, ouais.
Ouais. Moi c'est quelque chose que je trouve vraiment déchirant. Et tu parlais de la question de la séparation handicap psy, handicap physique.
En dehors du fait que je suis pas fondamentalement convaincue que cette distinction ait vraiment du sens,
mais en dehors de ça y a vraiment-- j'ai l'impression des mythes des deux côtés et vraiment moi j'en peux plus
de voir d'un côté-- du coup je précise pour les gens qui me connaissent pas, j'ai à la fois des handicaps psy et des handicaps physiques.
Et j'en peux plus de voir des personnes handicapées psy par exemple dire : « Oh là là, mais si seulement on traitait les maladies mentales comme on traite les maladies physiques ».
Mais on les traite pareil. L'endométriose c'est des hémorragies chroniques internes et on te dit : « Oh bah vous devriez boire une tisane et faire du yoga.
» On-- j'veux dire c'est pas parce que c'est physique que le validisme s'exprime fondamentalement différemment en fait.
Évidemment y a des variations. Et inversement, y a des personnes,
valides physiquement qui vont dire : « Ah oui mais en termes d'accessibilité nous on a telle et telle contrainte que vous vous avez pas », alors qu'en fait les personnes handicapées psy ont le même genre de contraintes.
Et y a un côté où effectivement y a toujours, à l'intérieur même de la communauté handicapée un peu des « moi et les autres ».
Et des fois positivement envers soi-même en mode : « Ah les autres ils sont quand même très handicapés alors que moi ça va ».
Ou inversement dans une position un peu : « Ah oui mais vous vous avez tel et tel droit, tel et tel respect alors que nous non ».
Alors qu'en fait dans notre majorité on est quand même tous dans la merde.
Et qu'on gagnerait vraiment à juste reconnaître que le validisme s'exprime certes de manière parfois variée et nuancée, mais quand même globalement, le validisme ne fonctionne pas par diagnostic en tout cas.
Il s'exprime par situation, suivant ta situation, suivant tes privilèges, suivant ton parcours, suivant à quoi tu te confrontes, mais pas tellement suivant comment tu es handicapé entre guillemets.
Et je pense que c'est vraiment important qu'on intègre ça et qu'on se dise en fait, ce dont on parle nous c'est comment on est traité et pas qui on est.
Et c'est ça notre lutte.
Mh. Tu as évoqué le misérabilisme. J'aimerais revenir là-dessus, la façon dont les personnes handicapées sont perçues.
Tout à l'heure Elisa, tu évoquais le Téléthon qui représente assez bien ça hein, cette vision, j'dirais, j'sais pas on peut parler de paternalisme ou de condescendance, de,
voilà on regarde les personnes handicapées de haut.
En particulier, et là je parle en tant que personne étrangère qui connaît très mal tout ça, mais
je pense comprendre qu'il y a en France deux lois, celle de 1975 ou 75 et celle de 2005 qui sont, voilà qui m'ont été décrites comme étant
issues de la droite tradi catholique caritative et que c'était, voilà, une certaine vision du handicap et le : « On est finalement des très bonnes personnes, nous qui nous occupons gentiment des personnes handicapées.
» Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire sur cette vision-là, cette vision caritative du handicap et la façon dont ces deux lois, 1975 et 2005, s'inscrivent là-dedans ?
Bah le fait que ce soit deux lois qui sont des lois justement prises par des gouvernements de droite, moi j'pense que c'est quand même très symptomatique de, voilà, de la situation en France.
J'pense pas que ce soit le fruit du hasard. C'est-- ça peut pas être le fruit du hasard. En fait, c'est vraiment un sujet que la droite s'est emparé-- dont la droite s'est emparée, j'veux dire.
Et c'est assez malheureux pour nous
puisque du coup, ce sont des lois qui, si on les regarde très rapidement, peuvent apparaître comme intéressantes, mais en réalité, y en a aucune d'elles qui a véritablement rompu
avec ce qui constitue l'injustice et le scandale majeur qui est l'institutionnalisation en France, en fait.
Ces deux lois continuent à considérer que c'est une option valable,
alors qu'on sait aujourd'hui que ne serait-ce que sur le plan international, il est acté que ce n'est-- c'est une privation de liberté qui est propre au handicap, qui ne se justifie pas et qui ne doit plus exister.
Donc voilà. Donc effectivement, ce sont des lois qui sont quand même avec une qui charrient une idéologie qui est celle que vous avez décrite, paternaliste, assez réac.
Et en fait y a jamais eu de propositions venant de la gauche plus ambitieuses en fait que ça. Parce que la gauche, elle s'est jamais penchée sur cette question
en offrant une analyse politique de gauche de la question du handicap, en fait.
La gauche, bizarrement, elle aussi, finalement, elle tient un discours assez proche qui va être, voilà, déconnecté des,
des idées religieuses peut-être, qui va être laïque, mais qui va sur le fond être quand même assez,
assez proche de celui qui est tenu par la droite.
Et en plus de ça, y a presque un conflit d'intérêt à gauche puisqu'y a beaucoup de personnes qui travaillent dans le milieu médico-social, à gauche.
Donc qui vont pas vouloir rompre avec ça non plus, puisqu'elles en dépendent économiquement. Donc on va se retrouver, nous, constamment en étau entre ces deux problématiques en fait.
Et du coup, deux camps qui devraient tenir des discours très très différents.
Et j'pense qu'à gauche, il devrait y avoir des propositions émancipatrices qui tiennent véritablement compte de ce qui existe en termes d'analyse politique du handicap, y compris s'il faut aller les chercher à l'étranger.
Mais y a Internet maintenant, j'pense, y a Google, donc faut peut-être un petit peu s'activer quoi.
Y a les réseaux sociaux, on mâche quand même pas mal le travail de notre côté, donc ce serait bien que les femmes et les hommes politiques de gauche comprennent qu'il est pas normal,
que leur discours soit aussi proche de celui de la droite et qu'il faut construire autre chose et sortir,
de cette idée que les personnes handicapées sont un problème à gérer, qui relèvent du médico-social et justifier tout cette espèce de monde parallèle qui a été mis en place.
J'suis très d'accord avec Elisa et j'rajouterais 'fin y a vraiment cette espèce de côté où le handicap parle n'importe quoi.
Où la droite parle du handicap d'une manière très, bah mauvaise, mais misérabiliste, paternaliste, catholique, conservatrice, eugéniste parfois.
Mh.
Ou parfois, des fois, quand ils veulent lutter pour l'eugénisme, pour lutter contre l'IVG, ils sont d'accord d'un coup, ils veulent nous défendre.
On sait pas trop. Quand c'est adéquat, c'est bon, ils sont prêts à nous défendre, mais sinon non.
Et donc y a d'un côté la droite qui s'empare du sujet, mais d'une manière complètement inadaptée, et de l'autre la gauche qui soit ignore le sujet, soit fait plus ou moins la même chose.
Et j'ai l'impression aussi sur la question des espèces de conflits d'intérêts, entre guillemets, où y a quelque chose à gauche de l'ordre des fois du
: il faudrait pas commencer à dire qu'en fait les services publics appliquent des discriminations.
Ouais.
Tu vois, où en fait le problème dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques, c'est le manque de moyens, tu vois. Il faut juste donner des moyens au service public et du coup, ils seront fonctionnels.
Je j'adore le service public, tu vois, sur le concept, c'est pas la question, mais c'est pas parce que c'est du service public qu'en fait les violences sociales et les systèmes d'oppression,
ils en sont supprimés, malheureusement.
Et du coup, y a un côté où en fait, quelque part, si tu critiques les violences en institut psychiatrique, c'est limite anti lutte des classes parce que t'es en train d'expliquer que genre les travailleurs font mal leur travail.
Mh.
Et genre en fait, c'est quand même plus compliqué que ça. Et de fait, j'suis désolée, mais une infirmière en hôpital psychiatrique et une personne internée en hôpital psychiatrique,
même si on veut parler de lutte des classes, clairement, l'infirmière, elle est,
elle est quand même dans une meilleure situation quoi.
Donc y a aussi cet enjeu-là, j'ai l'impression.
C'est très intéressant. Vas-y, Elisa, oui.
C'est vrai qu'à gauche, y a le travers qui consiste à opposer en fait finalement le personnel médico-social et les personnes handicapées.
Et à prendre le parti du personnel en défendant les conditions de travail
sans en ignorant en fait, sans vouloir affronter la question du rapport de force qui est également présent à l'intérieur des institutions médico-sociales, quelles qu'elles soient, en fait.
Du coup, c'est qu'il faut pas voir ça comme une opposition, il faut raisonner et ne pas oublier le groupe minoritaire dont les droits sont bafoués.
Il faut trouver des solutions qui permettent à tout le monde de travailler ensemble, de collaborer en fait. Y a des compétences qui se perdront pas.
C'est juste proposer des solutions qui fassent que les personnels, par exemple les gens qui appartiennent aux personnels médico-sociaux, travaillent autrement
et travaillent dans un environnement et dans un cadre où le pouvoir n'est plus détenu par eux.
Où en fait les personnes handicapées elles reprennent de l'agentivité et du pouvoir sur leur propre existence en fait.
Et donc cette vision que vous décrivez donc qui appartient plutôt à la droite française, voilà, condescendante, caritative, paternaliste.
Quand les personnes concernées directement, par exemple vous deux, bah je sais pas si vous avez eu l'occasion de vous adresser à des personnes,
des politiciens ou des personnes qui défendent ce point de vue-là, comment est-ce que c'est reçu quand les personnes concernées remettent ça en question ?
Mal.
Je soupçonnais cette réponse.
Ils le prennent pas très très bien.
D'accord.
Et c'est là qu'on voit que leurs bonnes intentions cachent souvent beaucoup de mépris et beaucoup de violence.
Ouais, tout à fait.
Et on passe très rapidement du paternalisme à l'agressivité. Donc voilà. Mais nous on n'est pas spécialement étonnés, on sait ce qu'y a derrière.
Donc voilà, ça ne fait que confirmer que y a un vrai problème et qu'il faut absolument le résoudre. Mais
évidemment que ça leur convient pas que on parle en notre nom et qu'on défende nos propres intérêts et qu'on remette en question leur vision des choses.
Je viens de me souvenir d'un épisode qui j'ai l'impression genre est un bon exemple si on veut essayer d'avoir un touché un plus concret.
L'autre jour, je me suis engueulée avec un assistant social sur Twitter. Voilà.
Formidable.
Un jour normal donc. Je parlais du fait que donc ça faisait plus d'un an que j'avais envoyé mon dossier à la MDPH, qui est donc la,
le, l'institution qui gère les allocations et les cartes priorité, enfin tout ce-- les aménagements liés au handicap.
Donc ça fait plus d'un an que je leur ai dit : « Bah voilà, je peux pas travailler, il faut que je paye mon loyer. » Ils m'ont toujours pas répondu.
Et donc cet assistant social vient me dire : « Oui, c'est pas normal » et tout. Je sais plus de quoi on parle.
Et à un moment, il me dit : « Mais du coup vous avez un assistant social ? » Je dis : « Bah non. » Enfin j'ai fait mon dossier moi-même avec mon médecin.
Il me dit : « Bah voilà, c'est ça le problème. » Et il me dit : « Hop, hop, hop, on va chez l'assistant social. » Tu vois.
Vraiment en ces mots-là. Et j'étais genre : « Quoi ?
» Et en fait plus j'essayais de lui dire : « Mais vous vous rendez pas compte que, un, ça sert à rien parce qu'en fait la MDPH, je leur envoie des mails toutes les semaines et ils me répondent, c'est juste qu'ils font pas leur travail.
Et c'est pas parce que quelqu'un d'autre va leur dire que d'un coup ils vont se bouger les miches. J'y crois pas des masses.
» Et en plus en fait plus la discussion avançait et plus y avait ce ton de : « Bah en fait forcément si vous essayez de faire les choses vous-même déjà c'est mal ».
Et en plus ouais, ce côté genre : « Hop, hop, hop, il faut y aller maintenant. »
Ouais. Un côté très, très dogmatique de : « La personne handicapée ne doit pas être autonome, ne doit pas être émancipée », enfin « je prends les choses en main ».
C'était si paternaliste. Et en fait à un moment quand j'ai commencé à lui dire : « En fait mais arrêtez de me parler quoi ».
Il m'a en gros dit : « Ah là là, mais moi depuis le début j'essayais de vous aider » et en fait il me disait : « Arrêtez de me parler sur ce ton sinon je vous aide pas », tu vois genre.
Mais en fait je ne vous ai jamais adressé la parole. Personne ne vous a rien demandé, en allez-vous.
OK. Donc il se croyait un peu dans le rôle du chevalier blanc de : « Mais je suis là pour vous aider enfin ».
C'est ça. Y a vraiment un côté où les personnes valides sont là et en fait tu leur demandes pas d'aide et elles sont quand même : « Et je vais arrêter de vous aider hein si vous continuez.
» Ou tout le temps en train de te dire : « Bah quand même il faudrait pas pousser le bouchon trop loin parce que quelque part si vous êtes vivant et si vous avez des conditions de vie décentes, c'est quand même toujours grâce à nous.
C'est jamais votre travail ou quoi que ce soit. » Et du coup y a cette dépendance qui s'installe où-- et c'est le cas au niveau systémique, mais aussi à l'échelle interpersonnelle.
On en parlait dans les violences domestiques. En dehors de la dépendance, juste,
en termes de manipulation psychologique,
quand c'est toi qui ramènes l'argent à la maison ou que tu fais un peu plus telle tâche ou que tu aides pour telle chose ou que t'aides juste la personne dans les tâches du quotidien, aller aux toilettes, se laver, s'habiller ou des choses comme ça,
c'est très facile de dire derrière : « Bah en fait je suis déjà bien gentil de t'aimer alors que t'es handicapé,
de t'aider à te doucher tous les soirs.
À un moment il va falloir accepter que je te tape dessus ou que je te viole. » Enfin concrètement c'est quand même ça qui se passe quoi à des moments.
Et cette dépendance-là elle est vraiment organisée. Et
non seulement être dépendant c'est nul, mais en plus le fait qu'on est dépendant nous est reproché comme étant notre faute et est utilisé pour qu'on accepte d'autant plus d'être violenté et d'être dépendant.
Donc c'est un espèce de cercle vicieux quoi. Puis d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose que les médecins nous disent. C'est-à-dire que-- 'fin tu vois là c'était un assistant social, c'est son métier, il est payé pour ça.
'Fin à un moment-- c'est-à-dire que les gens choisissent de faire un métier, ils sont payés pour ça et quand même il faudrait être reconnaissant qu'ils fassent leur métier.
Bah je vais quand même vous payer 25 € cette consultation, encore heureux que vous essayez de me soigner en fait. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous dise ?
Ouais alors je crois que la transition est tout indiquée vers le sujet qu'on évoque depuis tantôt, à savoir l'institutionnalisation.
De quoi s'agit-il précisément ? Si je pose la question à Elisa. Être institutionnalisée, quelque chose que tu as connu toi-même.
De quoi s'agit-il ? En quoi est-ce que c'est problématique ? En quoi est-ce que c'est, voilà une implémentation du système d'oppression dont on parle depuis tout à l'heure ?
Bah ça consiste à considérer que les-- pour répondre
aux besoins des personnes handicapées, la solution c'est de les faire vivre tous ensemble dans un lieu qui leur est réservé et encadré par des gens qui sont supposés avoir la compétence
pour pouvoir entre guillemets les prendre en charge.
Donc ça concerne les enfants comme les adultes. Et c'est un système de mise à l'écart et de ségrégation. Et le problème, c'est que c'est une atteinte aux droits des personnes handicapées, à la liberté des personnes handicapées.
Puisque une fois que vous êtes en institution, toute votre vie est régie par l'institution elle-même et par ses règles et par le fonctionnement collectif et par les, ouais les professionnels qui interviennent en fait.
Et sur le plan international, l'ONU, voilà,
a considéré que c'était pas une solution qui pouvait se défendre et qu'il fallait,
pour chaque pays qui,
qui a signé la Convention internationale relative aux droits des personnes handicapées, qu'il fallait entrer dans un processus de désinstitutionnalisation pour ceux qui ont encore des institutions, c'est-à-dire sortir de ce système, arrêter
de créer des institutions, arrêter de placer des gens en institution,
les fermer progressivement et prévoir
une alternative qui serait d'avoir des services de proximité pour permettre aux personnes handicapées qui en ont besoin de trouver les aides humaines et matérielles dont-- voilà, qui leur sont nécessaires quotidiennement.
Du coup, est-ce que la France a entamé cette transition et globalement, comment est-ce que ça a été reçu ? Puisque voilà, depuis tout à l'heure, on parle de la France comme étant
un peu le pays de la condescendance par rapport aux handicaps.
Bah la France, elle s'assoit, hein, très, très simplement sur ses engagements internationaux. C'est-- voilà, dans ce domaine comme dans bien d'autres, on se demande pourquoi elle signe des textes si c'est pour ne pas les respecter.
Mais en fait elle se sent pas concernée, elle continue à dire, y compris d'ailleurs une instance comme le défenseur des droits, ce qui est particulièrement grave, qu'en France, c'est différent.
En France, tout est bien, tout va bien.
En France, en France, tout est toujours différent. La France-
Voilà tout est différent
...la France est magique.
Exactement. C'est-- voilà.
C'est singulier. C'est...
Voilà. Vous ne pouvez pas comprendre en fait. Vous ne pouvez pas comprendre que tout se passe bien et que notre système, il est très bien.
Il est souverain.
Voilà. En gros, c'est ça. Voilà, donc en fait la France considère que c'est une position totalement extrémiste. Et donc elle essaye de tourner autour du pot.
Et là dernièrement, l'idée, c'était de réduire la taille des institutions, de changer le nom, voilà, d'opérer des modifications qui sont totalement cosmétiques, qui ne changent absolument rien à la problématique de fond.
Mais pour dire : « On a bien compris, on essaie de changer des choses, mais quand même, n'allons pas trop loin », en fait.
Alors que l'ONU, que je sache, c'est pas franchement une instance révolutionnaire.
Ce qui se passe, c'est que ce texte,
qui vient, voilà, dire à la France qu'il existe d'autres façons de raisonner,
bah ce texte, il tient compte du fait qu'il a été signé et négocié et rédigé en termes de contenu par des pays très différents les uns des autres, et dont certains ont cessé de cautionner ce système-là.
Et voilà, et ont réussi à faire ressortir de ce texte-là que ce n'était pas dans ce sens qu'il fallait continuer à aller si on voulait véritablement permettre aux personnes handicapées de vivre de façon autonome.
Je trouve que ce que dit Elisa est très symptomatique, c'est-à-dire qu'en fait, dire : « Peut-être qu'il faudrait pas nous séquestrer.
» C'est genre un point de vue extrémiste. C'est-- on en est là quoi, en termes de droits et de respect des personnes handicapées.
C'est juste l'idée que peut-être on pourrait genre habiter quelque part et avoir un logement à nous et une vie propre est déjà trop et impensable et irréaliste.
Quelle drôle d'idée. Ouais.
Et d'ailleurs, il me semble que la France a été condamnée au moins une fois, mais peut-être bien plusieurs, par la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme aussi,
pour ses pratiques en hôpital psychiatrique, qui sont considérées comme étant, je cite : « de la torture ».
Oui, bah, 'fin alors, on avait parlé de-- je crois qu'on avait parlé de ça avec Julie Dachez.
C'est bien possible.
Bon moi, je vous avoue que j'ai pas fait énormément de recherches vis-à-vis de la situation en Belgique, donc si ça se trouve, c'est encore pire, mais je ne pense pas. Ce serait dur.
On est quand même des champions en général.
Moi, en tout cas, je n'ai jamais été en prison parce que je suis autiste, donc a priori, c'est une bonne nouvelle.
Mais en fait,
faut quand même comprendre que le caractère pernicieux des textes, c'est de dire que les personnes sont libres, en fait, qu'on peut pas parler de séquestration au sens légal du terme, puisque
on vous dit qu'au fait les gens peuvent partir quand ils veulent,
que leurs droits fondamentaux sont respectés à l'intérieur et que de toute façon, si ça ne leur convient pas, ils peuvent parfaitement opter pour autre chose.
On a des termes-
Sauf qu'il y a pas d'autre chose.
Voilà, c'est ça. On a des termes dans les textes qui viennent parler, voilà, d'usagers, de,
d'offres. Bah Sophie Cluzel est toujours en train de mettre en avant le fait que c'est une offre,
comme s'il s'agissait d'un service commercial et que les personnes handicapées étaient des clients qui pouvaient librement choisir telle ou telle option, telle
ou-- telle ou telle, voilà, recette.
C'est totalement faux. Le problème, c'est que y a pas d'alternative. La plupart du temps, si vous voulez vivre en dehors de ce système, vous allez être entravé constamment, constamment, constamment.
On va pas ou peut vous donner les moyens de vivre votre vie en dehors des institutions. Et c'est ça qui est hypocrite et grave.
C'est de faire croire à ceux qui n'y connaissent rien qu'y a un choix possible. C'est faux en fait.
Le problème, c'est que par exemple pour ce qui concerne les enfants, y a beaucoup de parents handicapés, s'ils avaient véritablement un choix devant eux, ils choisiraient pas cette option-là en fait.
Simplement, ils savent ce qui les attend s'ils essaient de scolariser leurs enfants en milieu ordinaire et s'ils essaient de les sortir des institutions.
Ils seront pas soutenus, ils seront pas aidés, ils auront constamment des difficultés pour obtenir le minimum, pour pouvoir fonctionner.
Du coup, 'fin c'est vite vu quoi. C'est vite vu. L'institutionnalisation c'est vraiment la solution clé en main, y a pas à réfléchir.
Y a juste à signer quasiment, voilà, vous êtes OK, c'est bon. Vous avez plus à vous occuper de rien en fait.
On s'approche tout doucement de la fin de cet interview puisque voilà.
J'ai pu remarquer, et peut-être que je me trompe complètement, mais que tous les deux, sur Twitter, vous n'hésitez pas à tenir des propos bien marqués à gauche, bien anticapitalistes.
Est-ce que vous faites un lien direct entre les deux ? Est-ce qu'on peut distinguer la lutte antivalidiste de la lutte anticapitaliste ou bien est-ce que les deux sont fondamentalement liées ?
Mais Elisa par exemple, puisque je te vois souvent faire des tweets comme ça.
Je pense que les deux sont totalement liés parce que le capitalisme, c'est un système qui fonctionne sur l'exploitation.
Et du coup, oui, c'est comme je parlais du patriarcat qui s'articule avec le validisme, le capitalisme il s'articule aussi avec le validisme parce qu'en fait il se nourrit de toutes les oppressions en fait.
Et il les démultiplie et voilà. Donc du coup,
ce serait compliqué de mener une politique efficace, qui puisse véritablement émanciper les personnes handicapées si on raisonne pas non plus autour
de ce système-là économique, qui de toute façon vise aussi
à se servir de
toutes les inégalités et à exploiter les gens.
Tout à l'heure, Alistair parlait des ESAT. Bon, là, on est dans une situation totalement absurde et irréelle où y a des gens qui travaillent et qui sont pas considérés comme des salariés en fait.
Et personne ne trouve grand-chose à redire dans le fait qu'y a des personnes privées de leurs droits en matière de travail et ce sont des personnes handicapées.
Et pareil quand on raisonne autour de l'emploi des personnes handicapées, on veut jamais
véritablement aussi raisonner autour de : dans un système capitaliste, est-ce que quoi qu'on fasse, y aura pas toujours une difficulté puisque le but, c'est de faire le maximum d'argent en un minimum de temps.
Est-ce que dans un système comme celui-là, des personnes handicapées pourront véritablement trouver leur place ? Pas toutes, c'est sûr et certain.
Donc faut arrêter de vouloir à tout prix survendre le handicap pour améliorer l'emploi des personnes handicapées.
On n'y arrivera pas comme ça à mon avis. Il faut reconnaître le fait qu'il y a des personnes qui pourront peut-être jamais travailler.
Pour autant elles ont le droit d'avoir de quoi subvenir à leurs besoins de façon décente. Et y a des personnes qui pourront travailler, mais partiellement.
Et dans le travail, le travail ne s'apprécie pas uniquement par rapport à la quantité, mais aussi par rapport à la qualité.
Donc c'est tout un raisonnement autour de ces questions qui est à revoir si on veut véritablement pouvoir améliorer la situation en termes de travail pour les personnes handicapées.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que dit Elisa. C'est un peu le concept même de handicap que de dire qu'en fait y a des domaines dans lesquels on va être moins performant, moins efficace, moins autonome.
Et c'est pas grave en fait, ça arrive.
Mais juste, fondamentalement si tu penses de manière capitaliste en disant : « La vie a de la valeur parce qu'elle est rentable », forcément la vie handicapée aura moins de valeur.
Et on pense beaucoup l'insertion et l'amélioration de la qualité de vie des personnes handicapées par le travail
et l'enjeu de toutes les institutions qui ont pour rôle d'intégrer les personnes handicapées, c'est comment est-ce que-- alors on vous met à l'école pour ensuite vous mettre au travail
et c'est tout en fait.
Et beaucoup moins comment est-ce que vous vous épanouissez, comment est-ce que-- ou des questions de santé et de bien-être en fait, qui devraient être les premières questions.
Et par-dessus ça, je pense que c'est quand même important de rajouter qu'effectivement pour moi y a pas d'antivalidisme sans anticapitalisme et inversement, mais que dans les faits,
et on en a discuté tout à l'heure en fait avec la question de la gauche, y a aussi plein de gens qui font de l'anticapitalisme
partiel, je vais dire entre guillemets, parce que justement pour eux la question du handicap n'est pas une question.
Et je pense pas que dans une utopie communiste on ne se poserait plus la question du handicap et du validisme si elle ne s'est pas posée au moment où on a fait la révolution quoi en fait.
C'est ça dont on parle. Et donc 'fin voilà, c'était juste pour-- je suis tout à fait d'accord avec Elisa, c'était juste pour préciser que pour moi, dire l'anticapitalisme est fondamentalement antivalidiste et inversement, c'est-
C'est théorique
...c'est théorique. Dans les faits y a quand même de clairs problèmes d'antivalidisme dans les milieux anticapitalistes.
Elisa, Alistair, merci beaucoup d'avoir passé ces un peu plus que 70 minutes avec moi.
Avec plaisir.
On va faire la promotion de vos œuvres puisque vous êtes tous les deux auteurs, autrices. Elisa, tu viens de publier le 4 novembre dernier ton premier roman qui s'appelle Mister T
et moi. Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer un petit peu de quoi il s'agit ?
Alors moi je dirais que c'est une romance politisée ou une comédie romantique politique. C'est une... on pourrait dire une histoire d'amour.
Voilà. C'était pour évoquer justement la façon dont le validisme affecte ou voilà, interfère dans les relations notamment sentimentales, affectives ou sexuelles.
Et en fait, j'avais vraiment envie de raconter une histoire, de faire quelque chose qui soit pas théorique, et qui puisse parler à tout le monde ou on puisse-- un récit dans lequel on puisse entrer très très facilement.
Et je pense que beaucoup de personnes valides pourront justement s'apercevoir qu'elles peuvent parfaitement s'identifier à une personne handicapée qui est au centre d'un récit
et justement à une femme handicapée, parce qu'il y a peu de récits où le personnage principal, entre guillemets, est une femme handicapée.
Et du coup, j'avais vraiment envie de démontrer que c'était possible. Et de montrer aussi comment, en fait, le handicap justement est à la fois un sujet et un non-sujet en fonction de la situation.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des moments où c'est pas ce qui va être très important. On pourrait dire que n'importe quelle femme qui interagit dans un cadre hétérosexuel pourrait, voilà, se faire les mêmes raisonnements.
Et puis il va y avoir des moments où ça devient une question centrale et importante qui détermine le reste. Et je pense que ça correspond véritablement à ce que représente le handicap pour beaucoup de personnes handicapées.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas quelque chose qui nous résume, mais c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de notre identité et qui va, voilà, à des moments ou à d'autres, être une question plus primordiale qu'à un autre moment.
Donc c'était un peu ce que j'avais envie de faire à travers cette histoire-là. Et aussi raconter comment j'en suis venue à militer, quel a été le processus par lequel j'ai pris conscience qu'il fallait s'exprimer.
Oui. Ce qui est très réussi dans ce roman, c'est que c'est, comme tu le dis, à la fois beaucoup de propos, beaucoup d'idées politiques, politisées, très importantes, mais c'est délivré d'une façon très casual.
C'est bourré d'autodérision, c'est bourré d'humour. Tu vannes pas mal les politiciens français. J'ai pas toujours compris toutes les références parce que je suis un peu trop Belge et un peu trop jeune.
Mais c'est voilà, c'est vraiment humoristique et ça se veut hyper facile à lire. Donc oui, on le conseille.
Et comme on le disait, c'est sorti le 4 novembre dernier aux éditions Marabout dans la collection La Belle Étoile. Alistair, tu es aussi dans cette émission et tu es également auteur.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler de Plume, ta fable duveteuse pour interprètes étranges ?
Ouais, alors donc moi, je suis auteure plutôt de théâtre puisque je suis aussi comédienne de formation. Donc enfin, le théâtre, c'est
c'est le milieu artistique dans lequel je me sens chez moi et donc c'est celui que j'ai choisi pour parler de ces sujets-là aussi.
Donc Plume, c'est un récit initiatique. Donc c'est l'histoire d'un personnage handicapé qu'on suit du moment de sa naissance jusqu'à l'âge adulte.
Et en fait, toute la pièce est donc une fable animalière où c'est l'histoire d'un enfant qui grandit et qui essaye de faire comme les autres et échoue à un moment donné.
Et petit à petit, et c'est ce dont j'ai parlé plus tôt,
cette question en fait de l'épuisement quand on est handicapé, de-- on essaye de s'intégrer et puis plus le temps passe, plus on accumule de la fatigue et plus on perd notre capacité à s'adapter et à s'intégrer.
Et donc c'est ce chemin-là jusqu'au fond du trou. Et comment c'est ce moment avec lui-même et de retrouver son corps et son identité.
Et ce moment-là va dire : « En fait, ça y est, je comprends que depuis le début, ce qui se passe, c'est que je suis différent des autres.
Et en fait, j'ai essayé de faire comme tout le monde parce que personne me l'a dit. » Et il y a cette idée où en fait, c'est un enfant qui a essayé d'être un enfant et un jour, il s'est rendu compte que depuis le début, c'était un oiseau.
Et c'est pour ça qu'en fait, il arrivait pas à parler comme tout le monde. Son corps était juste pas capable de produire ça.
Allégorie.
Et il y a ce moment de colère en fait de : « Mais en fait, depuis le début, j'étais différent et personne ne m'a rien dit.
Et vous auriez pu me le dire et vous auriez pu me dire que c'était pas grave et vous avez préféré faire comme si de rien n'était.
Et c'est ça qui m'a détruit. » Et au final, du coup, cette renaissance de : « Ben du coup, aujourd'hui,
je vais le dire que je suis différent et je vais trouver les autres gens qui sont différents comme moi, plus jeunes, et je vais leur dire qu'ils sont différents et que c'est pas grave.
Et j'espère que ceux après moi grandiront oiseaux et que ce sera OK, en fait. »
On peut désormais, en cette période de confinement où les pièces de théâtre sont très difficilement accessibles, on peut acheter ça en version radiophonique sur...
Rappelle-nous où est-ce qu'on peut l'acheter, sur quel site ?
Sur HelloAsso. C'est le HelloAsso de ma compagnie qui s'appelle La Compagnie du Triangle Noir. Après, ceci étant dit, sur tous mes réseaux sociaux, il y aura les liens vers le HelloAsso et la page en question.
Donc si vous n'arrivez pas à retrouver ma compagnie, mais que vous me retrouvez moi, vous retrouvez la pièce aussi.
Il y a également la première scène, de la version radio de la pièce qui est sur ma chaîne YouTube. Donc ça permet d'écouter, de voir si,
si aussi sensoriellement, c'est quelque chose qui est accessible, parce qu'évidemment, la forme radio est un peu particulière. Et
Il y a un côté un peu ASMR, si je dis pas de bêtises.
Oui, il y a un peu de ça aussi. Donc voilà, tous les liens sont dans la description de la vidéo également.
Formidable. Et donc on peut rappeler que vous êtes tous les deux sur Twitter. Ton Twitter, Alistair, c'est H Paradoxæ, comme le nom de ta chaîne.
Et Elisa, tu es sur @ElisaRojasM. Je mettrai évidemment les liens dans la description. Merci beaucoup à tous les deux pour la sagesse que vous avez partagée avec nous et toutes vos connaissances sur ce sujet.
J'ai passé un très bon moment. J'espère qu'il en va de même pour vous.
Moi, ça va. Merci de nous avoir invités. Je suis très honorée d'avoir fréquenté Elisa Rojas pendant une heure quarante et un.
Il ne faut pas, il ne faut pas. Moi aussi, ça m'a fait très plaisir. C'était super cool. Merci pour l'invitation.
Super. Eh bien du coup, on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Je tiens à remercier encore une fois Elisa et Alistair pour leur présence. On a vraiment passé un bon moment à échanger sur ces sujets.
Un grand merci aussi à Eva, elle se reconnaîtra, pour son aide dans la préparation de cette émission. J'ai mis les liens dans la description vers le livre d'Elisa,
vers la chaîne YouTube d'Alistair, vers la première scène de Plume, ainsi que vers leurs comptes Twitter respectifs.
Si vous découvrez 70 minutes avec aujourd'hui, n'hésitez pas à remonter dans le temps et écouter les épisodes précédents.
J'ai reçu des gens formidables comme Julie Dachez, Olivier Klein, Rokhaya Diallo ou Olivia Gazalé. À part ça, le confinement secoue pas mal mon organisation pour les interviews ces jours-ci.
À la base, je comptais en fait sortir cet épisode-ci deux semaines plus tard. Normalement, normalement, croisons les doigts, je sortirai dans deux semaines un épisode avec Dave Sinardet, qui est politologue anversois et professeur à la VUB.
Pas mal de sujets à explorer et à approfondir dans l'actualité politique belge des derniers mois. Je trouvais ça important d'avoir un Flamand pour proposer un regard différent de ce qu'on entend d'habitude en Belgique francophone.
Je vous dis à très bientôt. Prenez soin de vous.